jean verso bonjour bonjour vous êtes
docteur ès-sciences physicien vous êtes
un spécialiste de l'intelligence
artificielle est aussi des robots on va
parler du colloque qui aura lieu le 25
mai sur le thème de l'accompagnement
mais à propos de ces robots vous êtes
même un pionnier puisque vous avez
organisé peut-être le premier colloque
mondial sur ce sujet c'était à saint
quentin
c'était il ya déjà 13 ans en 1990 80 23
ans 23 ans 23 ans 23 ans j'en étais on
était à l'onera office national d'études
et de recherches aéronautiques et
spatiales qu'on se préoccupe est donc de
l'envoi de petits robots sur mars avec
la le complexe hermès avec la règle
hélas la cellule hermès et donc il
fallait des petits robots et envoyer un
petit robot sur mars c'est une chose
mais il fallait un ouvrier un deuxième
et comment est ce que le deuxième allait
travailler en coopération est premier et
ensuite comment est ce que on allait
pouvoir constituer une une société de
petits robots
est-ce que ça pose des problèmes
d'impression comme ça que les robots il
faut ce qu'on leur demande de faire
oui quand ils sont tout seul ça marche
un peu près bien mais quand ils sont
deux ou trois et qu'il faut coopérer
vous voyez très bien que celui qui est
sûre sur mars ces joutes qui arrivent et
qui lui dit on alors qu'est ce que tu as
fait et bien voilà j'en suis là les
toits qu'il se passe un peu faire alors
le 25 mai il y aura un colloque donc sur
le thème de l'accompagnant pourquoi
avoir choisi ce thème de
l'accompagnement et bien
l'accompagnement est un problème réel à
l'heure actuelle problème important
parce que d'une part tout le monde
accompagne la mère accompagne son enfant
le père aussi à l'école on accompagne
les élèves au golf
vous avez le talent y est le golfeur a
dit c est qu on a
voilà voilà et on a un certain nombre de
problèmes dans notre société par exemple
comment accompagner un jeune qui sort de
l'université pour intégrer une
entreprise
pourquoi est-ce qu'on accompagne parce
que la personne est vulnérable quand
elle passe dans un certain nombre lieu
quand échange de milieux oui il faut
quand même pour minimiser les risques
pour minimiser les erreurs que la
personne soit accompagnée alors ça pose
évidemment toute une série de problèmes
dont le problème de rapports de pouvoir
entre l'accompagnateur et l'accompagnera
seulement ça pose ce projet accompagné
le problème de pouvoir entre
l'accompagné l'accompagnant ça pose des
problèmes aussi affectif ouais parce que
de l'affectif qui se met en place
et puis avec les dérives que l'on
connaît à l'heure actuelle dix sont ils
sont mises en évidence à l'heure
actuelle qui sont les dérives sexuelles
et puis il ya le problème de la
maltraitance et ça ce sont des problèmes
réels
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait pour résoudre
ces problèmes
eh bien on on fait des dérèglements on
met en place des procédures et on
demande aux gens de respecter ces
procédures justement pour éviter ces
dérives ont respecté les processus
visant non non parce que l'humain
l'humain des passes qui procédure
biaisée et seulement le vrai problème
c'est que on demande aux gens de
respecter les procédures
et ils sont notés sur leurs espérances
et d'ailleurs et il ne cherche qu'une
chose c'est respecter véritablement ces
procédures parce que leur carrière leur
job est en jeu donc la personne
accompagnée quelquefois elles passent au
second rang donc le vrai problème pour
moi c'est un problème de de conscience
conscience de celui qui accompagne les
consciences aussi de celui qui a
accompagné parce que même une personne
âgée est la conscience
une personne qui est handicapée mentale
a aussi conscience une personne qui est
dans le coma a aussi conscience donc
l'accompagnement est beaucoup plus un
problème de conscience a conscience et
quand on compose le problème de
conscience a conscience on arrive aux
problèmes de l'éthique c'est à dire du
respect d'un certain nombre de valeurs
qui sont les valeurs fondamentales de la
vie
le respect est là c'est amusant parce
que quand vous parlez du respect des
procédures des règles comme ça donc de
ses cinq compagnons qui se borne à
respecter les règles
j'avais l'impression wevelgem heathrow
motive exactement mais c'est exactement
ça donc dans la mesure où il ya des
règles à respecter des procédures à
respecter tant qu'il ya des procédures à
respecter le robot est impeccable oui
c'est ça qu'on le programme pour
responsable
or justement l'accompagnement ça n'est
pas donc le respect de procédures il
faut respecter les procédures
c'est sûr mais il faut aller aussi au
delà c'est à dire il faut être capable
de deux maîtrises et l'affectif que l'on
va avoir auprès du de celui qui est
coachée par exemple regarder entre les
nageurs les skieurs il ya une relation
affective qui se met en place entre le
coach et l'équipe il ya un respect
mutuel mais il ya quand même une
relation affective ou deux fois il y
avait un conflit l écosse voilà et ça
fait partie de la série
donc c
c'est là où est le mal il ya un mois et
quand il ya de l'humain il ya de la
confiance
il ya du respect il ya de l'affect il ya
de l'amour même et là où en sont les
robes ou à l'heure actuelle danser sur
ce plan là justement alors se disaient
les robots n'y arriveront jamais intégré
les mains justement maintenant de dire
ça c'est une
c'est une réelle question mais je pense
que on le problème je pense est mal posé
on a cherché à imiter les oiseaux on a
cherché à imiter des rigolos à voler
comme des aiguilles ya l'avion et
l'avion c'est pas demain mais l'avion il
nous sert beaucoup mais l'avion est
quand même un peu plein droit dans un
angle fermé et donc on peut penser que
joues avec autre chose c'est un robot
qui seront autre chose que des carcasses
qui ressemble à un être humain avec un
visage souriant et des lèvres maquillées
non c'est
et d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs les robots
les plus performants à l'heure actuelle
sont les robots qui sont dans les
bourses bourse de paris bourse de tokyo
ces bourses ces robots qui font des
opérations de bourse frais et qui mène
les meilleurs traders je mène ces voix
là et qui mêle l'économie avec
l'économie mondiale et est donc voilà
l'idée c'est que les robots ça sera ça
sera pas des humains ça sera autre chose
quoi ça il y aura certainement des
robots qui seront des dix ans des
humanoïdes oui mais je dirais à l'heure
actuelle on peut pas attendre beaucoup
ne peut pas attendre beaucoup mais tout
ce qui est fait en robotique c'est quand
même quelque chose de très fort de
prometteur qui permet d'apporter
énormément à l'être humain parce que le
robot doit être conçue aussi comme une
prothèse quand vous avez des gens qui
sont handicapés physiques apple et qu'
il même temps mes amis peuvent se mettre
dans une exauce un exosquelette qui les
aident à marché qui leur permet de
monter un escalier qui leur permet de
monter de supporter une charge
importante quand
vous n'avez plus l'usagé de vos jambes
et que vous pouvez monter un escalier ça
c'était un réel bien c'est vrai
seulement il ya pour moi la vraie
question c'est que la science la science
ne peut pas être réduite uniquement à la
technologie c'est ça oui et variés ben
on en parle est un tout petit peu avant
mais pas d'intelligence artificielle ou
parle aujourd'hui de conscience
artificielle conscience artificielle
donc c'est bien c'est bien cette idée
mais aussi conscience artificielle
alors il ya des recherches magasin
double c ur artificiel
les recherches qui ont été faites en
particulier par le professeur alain
cardon donc au havre qu'est maintenant à
roye en conscience artificielle et il
est arrivé à des des résultats
importants de ta critique même à tel
point que pour des raisons personnelles
pour des raisons d'éthique personnelle
il a stoppé la réalisation est stoppé la
réalisation c'est pour ça que c'est une
cata c'est rare c puis c'est une
attitude rare et qui mérite qui méritait
que l'on invite le professeur cardon à
venir nous parler à la fois de ses
recherches et les raisons du risque à
les raisons pour lesquelles voilà pour
l'été un mot sur le déroulement de ce
colloque
il est placé sous l'égide de la grande
loge de france pour quelles raisons
et bien pour la raison suivante vous
savez que la grande loge de france est
une obédience maçonnique
c'est une fédération c'est une
association régie par la loi 1901
c'est une fédération de loges
elle fédère à l'heure actuelle quelque
chose dont 859 sur le territoire de la
république française de tahiti aux
caraïbes et 7,7 fédération grande loge
de france propose à ses membres des ce
que je vais appeler des des plateformes
de réflexion des changes avec
l'extérieur des loges c'est à dire avec
le public
et parce qu'il ya des réflexions au sein
des voilà une réflexion au sein des
loges âge mais les exportent au sein des
loges c'est surtout la la pratique de la
méthode de travail c'est ça qui est
important c'est la pratique d'une
méthode de travail et comment est-ce
qu'on va utiliser cette méthode de
travail à l'extérieur comment est-ce
qu'on peut échanger avec cette méthode
de travail et donc qu'il ya une de ces
plateformes qui s'appelle le groupe de
réflexion éthique est une commission
obédience yale de la grande loge de
france et le grès off qui organise le
colloque le grès offs et une groupe de
réflexion éthique ouest francilien n'a
qu'à voilà est donc dans ce colloque qui
n'est pas du tout question de parler de
franc maçonnerie n'ont pas apporté des
réflexions c'est simplement de demander
aux médecins d'utiliser d'utiliser cette
cette méthode de travail le dernier basé
sur qui est très interactive ce qui veut
dire que le colloque ne sera pas une
succession d'interventions ou de mini
conférences ça sera vrai nazim à un
débat entre les intervenants autour de
la table ronde et j'espère bien avec le
public avec l'aco c'est donc le 25 mai
on a malheureusement plus de temps je
reviens mais parler avec vous dit
rationnels parce que vous êtes un des
rares scientifiques qui vous intéressait
aussi les rationnels au symbole
évidemment oui mais on fait qu'on aura
l'occasion de se rencontrer après le
colloque là on précise donc ce colloque
aura lieu à saint quentin à la faculté
de médecine
oui le 25 mai prochain et je dois dire
que
legré off et en particulier moi même je
remercie beaucoup à la fois le président
cas d'albert et la communauté
d'agglomération le président de
l'université
le président le doyen de l'ufr de les
accueillir et de nous soutenir dans
cette opération comme nous avons été
soutenus et il ya ya 23 ans alors c'est
une très belle histoire oui merci
beaucoup et verso merci